- How do we feel about like, PC culture?
- [Ajay] Are you talking
about like, cancel culture?
- [Cris] Canceling?
- Canceling, yeah, kinda.
- Canceling is fake, in my opinion.
(tense music)
It's not something that
actually is happening.
- [Narrator] If you had to
rank yourself against others
based on a specific trait,
what would it say about how you see them?
And how they see you?
We brought together five liberals
and had them rank each other
least to most politically left,
then we had them take the
Political Compass Test
and rearranged them based on
how left they actually are.
This is "Ranking."
- My name's Max.
(calm music)
I turned 24 today.
(children cheer)
It's my birthday.
I work in the video game industry.
- My name's Cris.
I'm 26 years old. Currently between jobs.
So I don't know, just a person living.
- I'm Ajay, I'm a...
I work in non-profit education.
I'm 27, yeah.
- I'm Brandee, I am 30,
and I own a wellness and lifestyle brand.
- I'm Alison, I'm 26
and I'm an ad writer, slash editor.
- So just straight into it,
just like, what I think would count
as like, a left leaning person?
- [Producer] Yeah, sure.
- Pushing for medical care for everyone,
free medical care for
everyone, stuff like that.
I want this person to be a living wage,
I want this person to
be living comfortably,
I want this person to just like, live.
If I had one thing to
say to people in general
("The Star Spangled Banner" plays)
in a large population is like,
fight for other people's rights,
fight for other people's comfortability,
make sure other humans are human to you.
- What I would prioritize,
(calm music)
versus someone on that
side would prioritize,
I would fair housing before most things.
'Cause if you guarantee housing,
I guarantee most problems would be solved.
- What would you be willing
to lose for that though?
- I would lose a good
amount of military spending
for fair housing.
- Of course.
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
- I think we all would.
- Yeah, I think we all agree on that.
- Because I think that there are people
that are conservative, maybe
not like, extreme right wing,
but they would say that
they believe in like,
LGBT rights, but they're
fiscally conservative.
"Oh, I'm pro whatever,"
but if you're not putting
money towards those things,
I just don't feel like
you're actually saying
that you believe in it.
- Would you guys be on like,
the whole Palestine-Israel situation?
(indistinct crosstalk)
Do you guys have an idea for a solution?
Two state solution? One state?
- Like a two state solution?
- Anything, really.
- No, because it's like, really hard.
But I do know that I care a
little bit more about that
than the Ukraine thing right now,
because it's not the worst thing I've seen
this past five years.
- That's a good point,
that there's all this like, all
the Ukraine flags everywhere
and everyone's throwing all the support,
when the Palestine-Israel conflict
has been happening for way longer.
How do we feel about like, PC culture?
- [Ajay] Are you talking about
cancel culture and all that?
- [Cris] Canceling?
- Canceling, yeah.
- Canceling is fake, in my opinion.
It's not something that
actually is happening.
- I'm gonna say Dave
Chappelle. (indistinct)
- Dave Chappelle, question mark?
- Has anyone's opinion changed of him
after that last special?
- There was a part in the special
where he said "Hey, I'm just a human
"going through an experience."
I think that was the main thing
that everyone kind of missed,
that when he was talking about his friend
that had passed away from all that,
I think he just got miss uh... ?
- Misquoted?
- Misquoted, yeah.
- I also think him saying
"I'm just a person having an experience"
is him just kind of
putting a cushion down.
Like "Hey guys, I know
you're gonna knock me,
"just don't hurt me too bad."
- Nah, but that's real though.
That is a real thing though.
- It is a real thing.
- [Producer] Do you guys have friends
who are right-wing?
- Yeah.
- I don't.
- There are certain things
that are sort of like,
deal breakers, right?
And so I have people, if
it's a deal breaker then no.
They're not friends.
- I got friends that are
on the right side spectrum.
I got cousins that are, I
guess you can say racist
or whatever.
I actually engage in
conversations with them
just because I want to see
where they're coming from.
- I would be cool to get to a point
where the right's like, "Oh wow,
"so these people genuinely
are pushing for stuff
"that does effect us
in a friendly manner."
- But do you think that people think that?
Do you think that people on the right
think everyone deserves a home?
Or do you think they feel like
"I worked and I earned this?"
- No, they don't think
that. Of course they don't.
- Their beliefs are so extreme
that it kind of crosses into
a morality question for me,
of like, who they are as people,
how they view other people,
and I don't wanna interact consistently
in a friend relationship
with someone like that.
- I don't think that just
because you label yourself
a certain way politically,
you can't be with people
who are on the other side.
It's not that they're bad people,
but it is sometimes, I think about like,
would they be my friend
if I was a certain color
or a certain like, religion?
Would they still like me?
- I grew up in the church.
I was in my church's band.
I had multiple weeks where I preached.
And then one day, I was like, "Oh man,
"this sucks."
These people have views
that are anti-human
while they're the ones here
preaching "Love each other.
"Love everyone."
I'm like, "You hate your neighbor.
"You're the ones telling
me that gay people
"deserve to burn in Hell."
I genuinely did lose a lot of friends
when I stepped out of that.
- So was it more personal
or more political though?
- It's probably more political.
A lot of people that are more pro-life.
It's like, "This is the
most normal thing we can do
"is be pro-choice," and they're like "No."
- Some women have a hard time
being able to get their tubes tied
if they don't have children.
- Yeah.
- Like, the doctor
decides they're too young.
(indistinct crosstalk)
It's a personal health decision
that's being taken away.
- We could move now.
(all laugh)
I don't know, I felt it was more about
trying to prove who's
the most of the most.
(tense music)
- Probably gonna go one over here maybe.
No, no, I think I'm over here.
- So then you would have to come back.
- I'm gonna put myself like, here.
I don't know, it's hard,
'cause it feels like we
all agree to a degree
on a lot of things.
- That's why I'm saying
we need to ask like,
a controversial question.
- Controversial question.
How do you feel about the police?
- I do think they're a necessary evil.
- I think regulation's important.
- Sir, you can move.
(Brandee laughs)
- Police unions, I think
police unions are like,
the biggest, strongest
unions in the country.
- They are.
- I don't know if I would say ACAB,
I don't know if I would go that far,
but I do believe in taking
some of their budget
and redistributing it to like,
services that will help people.
- The fact that the New
York police department
is like, the size of a
military is terrifying.
That's so scary.
And you see a lot of bad
things occur from that.
- For that reason.
- Do you... ?
- Here we go.
- Okay.
(playful music)
- Military?
- I mean, again, like a necessary evil.
- Yeah.
- I'm very pro-military.
- Well, I just got a
lot of friends who like,
for economic purposes
had to join the military.
And the military teaches you
a lot of things about life
and discipline which helps people
translate into the civilian life, I feel.
- Do you feel like there's
a bigger issue there though?
Like, that people have
to go into the military
in order to be economically sound?
I feel like it's a jobs program.
- It's predatory, that's predatory.
- Exactly.
- That's like, yeah.
- And we're allocating
this money to weapons
that aren't needed, insane things.
I'm not a big fan of the military.
- Okay, I'mma move over.
Yeah, okay, cool.
I think the military overall,
like 90, 90 10, is like better than not.
- I think it is very,
very conservative to be very pro-military.
That's like a poster
conservative ideology.
- I'm personally pretty
pro-military but I don't know.
I'm not that passionate about it
to get into the
conversation they're having.
- Okay, I kind of have a question
about like, representative diversity.
A lot of times, when
we talk about diversity
and things like that,
it's never a progressive,
it's always just like,
appearance based diversity.
- I care more about policies
than being represented.
- Yeah, like I could care less who...
But yeah, like the policy.
- You know, I'm definitely
for we need to diversify.
Like, models or people that
we see in these industries,
but I do think it should
be more like, who they are.
- I mean, 'cause like,
equity's the goal, right?
Like, if we did a better job
of identifying differences
in the first place,
then we wouldn't have so
much time making up for it.
Color blind society led
to this issue with DEI,
which I like, find really annoying.
Every training I have to go to.
Anyone like, particularly
pro-capitalism or like, anti?
- I'm kind of anti. I'm pretty anti.
- Okay, okay.
- I mean, I participate
in it because you got to.
- I think I'm in the camp, I'm like,
more of an equitable capitalist.
Like, I feel like we could
do capitalism better.
Or like, we could fix it.
- I think it's cool
like, the guy in Seattle
that forfeited his wage
and turned everyone's wage to $71,500.
- [Ajay] Oh, Dan Price? Dan Price, yeah.
- We are in a world
where people have yachts
and are going to space for fun,
while there are people
dying on the streets
and starving.
You know, if you can give more,
I think you could and you should,
just because it's a group.
- How much does one person need really?
- Yeah, right?
- But who defines that
besides the person themselves?
- But like, the system
that we all were born into
and our parents were born into,
we all kind of were opt
into the capitalist system
where we kind of thought like,
"We can make the most
money, you earned it,"
and all that stuff,
but Jeff Bezos got all that money, bro,
and we got hella homeless
people on Skid Row.
What's up with that?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, but the thing is
it's still illegal to take his money.
- (beep) that. (beep) that.
Nah.
You know, we got politicians
not really care about
the well being of the working class people
and stuff like that.
Minimum wage is still 7.25, you know.
What are we doing here, guys?
- So here's like, a question though.
I guess, so,
I want the best for everyone
but that also kind of puts
some personal responsibility on it.
I don't want someone to just kind of like
get a bunch of money and then do nothing.
- I think that's definitely
a very left-leaning thing
to think about how everyone
should be up and working
and doing that.
I think that's more than fine to say
because I think everyone
contributes for a society to work.
- Some of what you just said right now,
I feel like I might be
on the other side of you
on that issue.
People work so hard and it's
not like it's a fair game
to start out with.
So sure, yeah, people
shouldn't be just like,
sitting if they can do something else,
but if they can't, they
still deserve comfort
and to live like, a life of dignity.
- I don't think I care what they're doing.
- Just doing something?
- Something.
- What if they just wanna
relax and chill man?
Life is stressful,
sometimes you just wanna
have a good like...
- And yeah, and that's like, I don't know.
(indistinct crosstalk)
I don't think there is
anything wrong with that.
- [Producer] Okay, you
guys are now going to go
to politicalcompass.org
and take the test there.
In spot number five, Alison.
(Alison laughs)
- Solid.
- [Cris] Nice.
- [Producer] In spot
number four, we have Max.
- Yo.
- I was kind of surprised
that Max was like, next to me.
He just gave me vibes of someone
who was more like, anti-establishment,
anti like, capitalism, more
like anarchy kind of vibes.
- [Producer] In spot number
three, we have Cristian.
- Hey, nice.
- [Producer] In spot
number two, we have Ajay.
- Oh, okay. Nice.
- [Producer] In spot number
one, we have Brandee.
- Interesting.
- [Alison] So we weren't close.
(Alison and Brandee laugh)
(tense music)
- I do firmly believe things are on me,
and like, I'm gonna lean left
because I just care.
- I kind of expected you guys maybe
to pick like, one random
conservative to throw in there
to kind of like, throw us out.
But it was cool.
- It was cool to see how similar
we all felt on some things
but then also, how there
are definitely things
that are like, more deviating,
but we also agreed that
we're all liberals,
we're all part of this.
- I honestly thought it was gonna
maybe be in the three spot.
- Yeah, I don't know,
but it's hard to like,
range people on like...
- I wonder what I chose
that was more of a conservative thought.
I was still pretty far
left on that compass,
so that's crazy.
(Max laughs)
Like, it's impressive.